good evening i'm mr
pat and i'm back
good afternoon residents lunch will be
served in
five minutes our special item of the day
fruit
cocktail scotch you always had beautiful
ham
beautiful patrick pitzenberger
it's been years i'm retired rita parker
sloane
passed away rita specified that you
do her hair and makeup for the funeral
the will makes a provision for services
rendered
my client demand high quality beauty
products
what you looking for perfect powder
bleach and vivonte
baby that smack don't stick the nappy
heads
oh my god pat was it you yeah look so
athletic
i'm surprised you still remember me who
could forget the
liberace of sandusky
i supposed to make a death look
human or is he a handful
oh a demanding republican monster
sounds like a nightmare i adore her
holy hell pat you're still alive
i used to perform there must have been
before my time since
facebook's family girl you taught me
everything i never wanted to know
even though i never really knew you i
want you to know you changed my life
well ain't you just the sweetest thing
pick me
[Music]
you